so look at the cleanliness they locked
up more nonviolent drug offenders
including a record amount of women for
doing the exact same fences that Bill
Clinton was there in I mean Bill Clinton
his brother Roger got arrested in a drug
deal he said he was buying some of it
for bail cuz he's got a nose like a
vacuum cleaner yet yet yet these
hypocritical bastards lock up hundreds
of thousands of people criminalizing
young people ruining their lives half of
my friends in prison was was veterans
soldiers come back from wars that
they've been duped into by Bush and
Clinton and then they go don't get any
help they get PTSD and they end up on
street drugs but when Hillary was up
with the last election
she was spouting off about mass
incarceration and how terrible it was
for you know the black people and the
women so when you've got evil
psychopaths in power and I believe it's
only the Psychopaths that can rise to
the top of politics right bear the
biggest crooks in the world the people
have got to put the pressure cuz the
skirt of the votes and it's the people
voting at the state level that is
decriminalized and legalized weed and
this causes reversal worldwide because
America that introduced all these laws
to the entire world
the earliest cannabis laws with
pharmaceutical societies in California
they wanted it illegal because they
didn't want people growing free medicine
in their own backyards then at the
federal level Harry Anslinger came in he
was working for Andrew Mellon and all
these other interests fledgling
petrochemicals
farmer plastics and a demonized it and
said you know black man on marijuana
will want to rape every white woman in
sight went to the United Nations and
said to the entire world if you don't
sign on for America's drug laws
America's not going to trade with you so
that's why the whole world has got all
this violence right now
everything from knife crime in London so
all these people dying in Mexico that is
to do with drugs being illegal and
criminals competing for that black
market profit
by making drugs illegal they made
worthless plants more valuable than gold
weed was called weak as it grew the
sides of roads Pablo Escobar could get
coca paste the $60 a kilo and because of
drug laws he could sell it for 60,000
aquila on the streets of america when he
was getting started in the 70s so drug
laws have created the biggest profits
opportunity in the history of the world
for the cartels and the politicians know
this because they saw the same thing
happened with alcohol prohibition right
Al Capone's running around with his
machine guns people getting slaughtered
people are getting corrupted well
they've not stopped it with drugs
because they've learned to profit from
it the contracts are in the tens of
billions a year for the private prisons
and that's just one entity parasitical
entity there are hundreds of them
everything from razor wire to telephone
services three strikes law in California
three crimes and you're serving life
they have people there in life of
stealing pizzas and chocolate chip
cookies 25 years times fifty thousand
dollars 1.25 million for ten a ten
dollar pizza so the California taxpayers
were like why are we doing this this
doesn't make sense they tried to get it
reversed and when they tried to get it
reversed the wall of money rose up and
stopped it and the two principal sources
were the prison guards Union of
California which had paid up to the
governor off I think was like a million
to get three strikes introduced in the
first place and one of the founders of
Broadcom exclusive provider of telephone
services to the California state prison
system Wow
that is it that is a heap that you just
dropped that the US US justice system US
justice system is one of the biggest
employers in the world if they legalize
drugs it would whack the US economy
because all those courts would be MC all
those jail cells will be NC all those
people in those bumpkins sounds are
working as prison guards will be
unemployed again it would slam the
economy so hard
these vested interest just keep it going
I mean I'm sure you keep up with it but
as far as the next presidential election
in the u.s. who do you like if you were
living in the US and you were a US
citizen who do you like that that's
running so far okay so so I view all
people at the top of politics as
absolute Psychopaths okay and I'm an
observer of politics I don't participate
I've never voted I am you know
interested in the different characters
that we rise to the top and I have
extensively researched the bush crime
family in the Clinton crime families and
that's that's how you know I came to
these conclusions and came to write this
war on drugs series of books so I've not
researched Trump that much but we're
seeing a rise of populism worldwide in
the UK here the people voted for brexit
that was part of that I do talks across
the country I go in these small towns
and I hear the people who are pro brexit
and it's crazy because the Conservative
Party here got that vote and they
typically don't because they're
typically what the wealthy people vote
for well because they're working a lot
of working-class people with pro brexit
they voted for the conservative party so
the Conservative Party has learned how
to harness the votes of the poor people
but it's now it's that rise of populism
if you can ride that if you can attach
onto that right now you will win your
the election because that's happening
worldwide and you know I read over a
thousand books in prison and just under
six years a lot of history philosophy
psychology and if you go back to the
1900s exactly the same thing happened
than it was a precursor for the world
wars